what's going on in your life
you need something so badly that has an
end that you can train for and that has
an end do you know what you mean it's
like just
go home and see your kids
[Music]
i'm annie letterman and i'm here to
answer the internet should you lock a
dog out of the room when you're having
sex no let them in put a little peanut
butter in the middle threesome
include your dog that's your kid if you
could only have four teeth in your
entire mouth where would they be i would
have them actually in my vagina
and tada baby
how much money would you take for
uh how much
you guys i was a jewish i was a juvenile
delinquent i skipped eighth grade i
skipped eighth grade i graduated when i
was 16. i graduated you're right i
should have known a read before then
my mom was busy reading and didn't teach
me to read romance novels soggy
hopefully from the bath water like oh 50
shades of gray is sticky
how much money would it take for you to
strangle a puppy i don't think i would
kill a dog this is like the girl
equivalent of like how much money to
suck a guy's dick did you ask to a
straight guy all right you know what you
know what actually
i have a good answer for this it
actually would be no money because the
dog might um choke on my boyfriend's
[ __ ] when i put all of the peanut butter
on it when we're having the threesome or
maybe we get strangled by the four teeth
i have in my vagina that's what we call
a callback
okay if you could have one person
narrate or do play-by-play of you having
sex who would it be god because i'd like
to know why i haven't come yet
would you rather a have a flock of geese
swarm to you every time you fart or b
never use a phone or computer again the
geese flocking to swarm your fart is
great never alone
you could blame the smell of the fart on
the geese like these geese smell like
[ __ ] dude
which one of these geese [ __ ] farted
or you could just pretend you don't
notice because you're on your [ __ ]
phone
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blind child who has the greatest
voice of our generation
are you killing the kid i mean he's
already blind like a singing voice yeah
who cares or you can grow up who gives a
[ __ ] if someone can sing [ __ ] so
embarrassing it moves people to tears
and [ __ ] that's like you know but he
can't even see it he can't even see the
joy he's bringing get out of here
what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown at you wait do you want me to
start reading the cards
that's just not what it says at all
what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown out of a bar for i got thrown out
of a bar
for uh getting in a slap fight with my
friend a bunch i had this one friend in
santa fe and every time we'd see each
other albert we'd take our glasses off
we'd just slap each other and i'd be
laughing crying it was the funniest
thing in the world but he was like a
real man
like yeah he'd be smacking me against
the wall i'd be smacking yes my friend
albert it was so funny and the security
guard would be like guys you really
can't do they'll be like all right judy
and he would like turn around
would you rather have a dog die every
time you laugh
or have there be a genocide every time
you fall in love genocide every every
time you fall in love because i've only
fallen in love once and that was back in
the cold war no i don't know when was
the last genocide i don't i can't read
uh for a reason i didn't go to school
how long would you starve to become a
cannibal how long would you have to
starve to become a cannibal she's just
skipping entire words
um what if i thought it was cannonball
oh this is actually not that bad well
you have to wait a half and you have to
wait a half hour because you can't go in
the pool you get a cramp
what is a little thing someone can do
that automatically makes you a cra makes
them
that was projection what is a little
thing someone can do that
automatically makes them a crazy person
i feel like shadowboxing in the sun on a
corner
is usually
do you know what i mean they're always
winning too it's like oh you're
obviously losing
if you had the opportunity to turn
someone into a [ __ ] we don't say that
word we say little person listen they
come to my show always like raise your
hand put them on their shoulders if you
had the opportunity to turn someone into
a little person
who would it be is anyone even tall here
to do that to
well looks like god did it for me
already
you [ __ ] would you have sex with a dead
person for five minutes if you get your
laundry done and folded magically for
you for the rest of your life so are you
a little curious like do you have to die
with a boner for it to be hard like do
am i trying to get a dead guy hard i
mean
i've already gone to college so i think
i'll do my own laundry
what movie most recently made you cry oh
i watched um oh my god what was it no i
didn't watch black widow i don't watch
movies about black people um what made
me cry
but a black woman whose husband died i
was like this is so [ __ ] depressing
somebody marry her this is crazy
if she's not remarried by the end of
this thing i'm [ __ ] out of here
i did cry it um actually light life
itself did you see the movie oh my god
watch that movie but realize like
it's not okay
life itself it's not okay
would you watch a sex tape of your
number one celebrity banging your arch
enemy of course i would because i hate
myself
come on leave schreiber let's do it
now [ __ ] you ray donovan
what's worse people who run marathons or
polar plunge people well
one is my king mr joe rogan this is the
thing i feel like about people that run
marathons it's like what's going on in
your life
you need something so badly that has an
end that you can train for and that has
an end do you know what i mean it's like
just go home and see your kids okay
they miss you
would you rather have to tell your mom
everything sexual you've ever done or
have to show her your entire pornistry
listen my mother knows most of my sex
history my mom actually said to me she
told my sister-in-laws that i am
infertile and i was like why would you
say that and she's like oh i just
figured you like had sex with so many
guys that and you never got pregnant i
went
i only [ __ ] them once mom
like [ __ ] if you had to choose one
cartoon animal to have sex with who
would it be uh peppa pew i love it
i love a half black guy
all right did the abs look good
i mean reading is a challenge english is
my second language my first language is
being called a cunn by my father
is that a language
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel
set reminders with a little bell comment
who you want to see do it and watch all
the other answer the internets i don't
know where anything is so i'm kind of
just moving my hands around but do all
that [ __ ] subscribe comment reminder
watch others you're welcome don't know
why but you're welcome